all right let's get started
this is 682 for distributed systems so
I'd like to start with just a brief
explanation of what I think a
distributed system is you know the core
of it is a set of cooperating computers
that are communicating with each other
over networked to get some coherent task
done and so the kinds of examples that
we'll be focusing on in this class are
things like storage for big websites or
big data computations such as MapReduce
and also somewhat more exotic things
like peer-to-peer file sharing so
they're all just examples the kinds of
case studies we'll look at and the
reason why all this is important is that
a lot of critical infrastructure out
there is built out of distributed
systems infrastructure that requires
more than one computer to get its job
done or it's sort of inherently needs to
be spread out physically so the reasons
why people build this stuff so first of
all before I even talk about distributed
systems sort of remind you that you know
if you're designing a system redesigning
you need to solve some problem if you
can possibly solve it on a single
computer you know without building a
distributed system you should do it that
way and there's many many jobs you can
get done on a single computer and it's
always easier so distributed systems you
know you should try everything else
before you try building distributed
systems because they're not they're not
simpler so the reason why people are
driven to use lots of cooperating
computers are they need to get
high-performance and the way to think
about that is they want to get achieve
some sort of parallelism lots of CPUs
lots of memories lots of disk arms
moving in parallel another reason why
people build this stuff is to be able to
tolerate faults
have two computers do the exact same
thing if one of them fails you can cut
over to the other one another is that
some problems are just naturally spread
out in space like you know you want to
do interbank transfers of money or
something well you know bank a has this
computer in New York City and Bank B as
this computer in London you know you
just have to have some way for them to
talk to each other and cooperate in
order to carry that out so there's some
natural sort of physical reasons systems
that are inherently physically
distributed for the final reason that
people build this stuff is in order to
achieve some sort of security goal so
often by if there's some code you don't
trust or you know you need to interact
with somebody but you know they may not
be immediate malicious or maybe their
code has bugs in it so you don't want to
have to trust it you may want to split
up the computation so you know your
stuff runs over there and that computer
my stuff runs here on this computer and
they only talk to each other to some
sort of narrow narrowly defined network
protocol assuming we may be worried
about you know security and that's
achieved by splitting things up into
multiple computers so that they can be
isolated the most of this course is
going to be about performance and fault
tolerance although the other two often
work themselves in by way of the sort of
constraints on the case studies that
we're going to look at you know all
these distributed systems so these
problems are because they have many
parts and the parts execute concurrently
because there are multiple computers you
get all the problems that come up with
concurrent programming all the sort of
complex interactions and we're
timing-dependent stuff and that's part
of what makes distributed systems hard
another thing that makes distributed
systems hard is that because again you
have multiple pieces plus a network you
can have very unexpected failure
patterns that is if you have a single
computer it's usually the case either
computer works or maybe it crashes or
suffers a power failure or something but
it pretty much either works or doesn't
work distributed systems made up of lots
of computers you can have partial
failures that is some pieces stopped
working other people other pieces
continue working or maybe the computers
are working but some part of the network
is broken or unreliable so partial
failures is another reason why
distributed systems are hard and a final
reason why it's hard is that you know
them the original reason to build the
distributed system is often to get
higher performance to get you know a
thousand computers worth of performance
or a thousand disk arms were the
performance but it's actually very
tricky to obtain that thousand X speed
up with a thousand computers there's
often a lot of roadblocks thrown in your
way so the Elven takes a bit of careful
design to make the system actually give
you the performance you feel you deserve
so solving these problems of course
going to be all about you know
addressing these issues the reason to
take the course is because often the
problems and the solutions are quite
just technically interesting they're
hard problems for some of these problems
there's pretty good solutions known for
other problems they're not such great
solutions now distributed systems are
used by a lot of real-world systems out
there like big websites often involved
you know vast numbers computers that are
you know put together as distributed
systems when I first started teaching
this course it was distributed systems
were something of an academic curiosity
you know people thought oh you know at a
small scale they were used sometimes and
people felt that oh someday they'd be
might be important but now particularly
driven by the rise of giant websites
that have you know vast amounts of data
and entire warehouses full of computers
distributed systems in the last
twenty years have gotten to be very
seriously important part of computing
infrastructure this means that there's
been a lot of attention paid to them a
lot of problems have been solved but
there's still quite a few unsolved
problems so if you're a graduate student
or you're interested in research there's
a lot to you let a lot of problems yet
to be solved in distributed systems that
you could look into his research and
finally if you like building stuff this
is a good class because it has a lab
sequence in which you'll construct some
fairly realistic distributed systems
focused on performance and fault
tolerance
so you've got a lot of practice building
districts just building distributed
systems and making them work all right
let me talk about course structure a bit
before I get started on real technical
content you should be able to find the
course website using Google and on the
course website is the lab assignments
and course schedule and also link to a
Piazza page where you can post questions
get answers the course staff I'm Robert
Morris I'll be giving the lectures I
also have for TAS you guys want to stand
up and show your faces the TAS are
experts at in particular at doing the
solving the labs they'll be holding
office hours so if you have questions
about the labs you can come you should
go to office hours or you could post
questions to Piazza the course has a
couple of important components one is
this lectures there's a paper for almost
every lecture there's two exams
there's the labs programming labs and
there's an optional final project that
you can do instead of one of the labs
the lectures will be about two big ideas
in distributed systems they'll also be a
couple of lectures that are more about
sort of lab programming stuff a lot of
our lectures will be taken up by case
studies a lot of the way that I sort of
try to bring out the content of
distributed systems is by looking at
papers some academics some written by
people in industry describing real
solutions to real problems
these lectures actually be videotaped
and I'm hoping to post them online so
that you can so if you're not here or
you want to review the lectures you'll
be able to look at the videotape
lectures the papers again there's one to
read per week most of a research paper
some of them are classic papers like
today's paper which I hope some of you
have read on MapReduce it's an old paper
but it was the beginning of its spurred
an enormous amount of interesting work
both academic and in the real world so
some are classic and some are more
recent papers sort of talking about more
up-to-date research what people are
currently worried about and from the
papers we'll be hoping to tease out what
the basic problems are what ideas people
have had that might or might not be
useful in solving distributed system
problems we'll be looking at sometimes
in implementation details in some of
these papers because a lot of this has
to do with actual construction of of
software based systems and we're also
going to spend a certain time looking at
evaluations people evaluating how fault
tolerant their systems by measuring them
or people measuring how much performance
or whether they got performance
improvement at all so I'm hoping that
you'll read the papers before coming to
class the lectures are maybe not going
to make as much sense if you haven't
already read the lecture because there's
not enough time to both explaining all
the content of the paper and have a sort
of interesting reflection on what the
paper means online class so you really
got to read the papers before I come
into class and hopefully one of the
things you'll learn in this class is how
to read a paper rapidly in the fish
and skip over the parts that maybe
aren't that important and sort of focus
on teasing out the important ideas on
the website there's for every link to
buy the schedule there's a question that
you should submit an answer for for
every paper I think the answers are due
at midnight and we also ask that you
submit a question you have about the
paper through the website in order both
to give me something to think about as
I'm preparing the lecture and if I have
time I'll try to answer at least a few
of the questions by email and the
question and the answer for each paper
due midnight the night before there's
two exams there's a midterm exam in
class I think on the last class meeting
before spring break and there's a final
exam during final exam week at the end
of the semester the exams are going to
focus mostly on papers and the labs and
probably the best way to prepare for
them as well as attending lecture and
reading the papers a good way to prepare
for the exams is to look at all exams we
have links to 20 years of old exams and
solutions and so you look at those and
sort of get a feel for what kind of
questions that I like to ask and indeed
because we read many of the same papers
inevitably I ask questions each year
that can't help but resemble questions
asked in previous years the labs there's
for programming labs the first one of
them is due Friday next week lab one is
a simple MapReduce lab to implement your
own version of the paper they write
today in which I'll be discussing in a
few minutes
lab 2 involves using a technique called
raft in order to get fault taught in
order to sort of allow in theory allow
any system to be made fault tolerant by
replicating it and having this raft
technique manage the replication and
manage sort of automatic cut
or if there's a field if one of the
replicated servers fails so this is rav4
fault tolerance in lad 3 you'll use your
raft implementation in order to build a
fault tolerant key-value server it'll be
replicated and fault tolerant in a lab 4
you'll take your replicated key-value
server and clone it into a number of
independent groups and you'll split the
data in your key value storage system
across all of these individual
replicated groups to get parallel
speed-up by running multiple replicated
groups in parallel and you'll also be
responsible for moving the various
chunks of data between different servers
as they come and go without dropping any
balls so this is a what's often called a
sharded key value service sharding
refers to splitting up the data
partitioning the data among multiple
servers in order to get parallel speed
up if you want instead of doing lab 4
you can do a project of your own choice
and the idea here is if you have some
idea for a distributed system you know
in the style of some of the distributed
systems we talked about in the class if
you have your own idea that you want to
pursue and you like to build something
and measure whether it worked in order
to explore your idea you can do a
project and so for a project you'll pick
some teammates because we require that
projects are done in teams of two or
three people so like some teammates and
send your project idea to us and we'll
think about it and say yes or no and
maybe give you some advice and then if
you go ahead and do if we say yes and
you want to do a project you do that and
instead of lab 4 and it's due at the end
of the semester and you know you'll you
should do some design work and build a
real system and then in the last day of
class you'll demonstrate your system
as well as handing in a short sort of
written report to us about what you
built and I posted on the website some
some ideas which might or may not be
useful for you to sort of spur thoughts
about what projects you might build but
really the best projects are one where
sort of you have a good idea for the
project and the idea is if you want to
do a project you should choose an idea
that's sort of in the same vein as the
systems that were talked about in this
class
okay back to labs the lab Greed's they
we give you you hand in your lab code
and we run some tests against it and
you're great early based on how many
tests you pass we give you all the tests
that we use those no hidden tests so if
you implement the lab and it reliably
passes all the tests and chances are
good unless there's something funny
going on which there sometimes is
chances are good that if you your coop
passes all the tests when you run it or
pass all the tests when we run it and
you'll get a four score full score so
hopefully there'll be no mystery about
what score you're likely to get on the
labs let me warn you that debugging
these labs can be time-consuming because
they're distributed systems and a lot of
concurrency and communication sort of
strange difficult to debug errors can
crop up so you really ought to start the
labs early don't don't even have a lot
of trouble if you be elapsed to the last
moment you got to start early if your
problems please come to the TAS office
hours and please feel free to ask
questions about the labs on Piazza and
indeed I hope if you know the answer
that you'll answer people's questions on
Piazza as well all right any questions
about the mechanics of the course yes
so the question is what is how does how
do the different factor these things
factoring the grade I forget but it's
all on the it's on the website under
something I think though it's the labs
are the single most important component
okay alright so this is a course about
about infrastructure for applications
and so all through this course there's
going to be a sort of split in the way I
talk about things between applications
which are sort of other people the
customer somebody else writes but the
applications are going to use the
infrastructure that we're thinking about
in this course and so the kinds of
infrastructure that tend to come up a
lot our storage communication and
computation and we'll talk about systems
that provide all three of these kinds of
infrastructure the the storage it turns
out that storage is going to be the one
we focus most on because it's a very
well-defined and useful abstraction and
usually fairly straightforward
abstraction so people know a lot about
how to build how to use and build
storage systems and how to build sort of
replicated fault tolerant
high-performance distributed
implementations of storage we'll also
talk about some some of our computation
systems like MapReduce for today is a
computation system and we will talk
about communications some but mostly
from the point is a tool that we need to
use to build distributed systems like
computers have to talk to each other
over a network you know maybe you need
reliability or something and so we'll
talk a bit about what we're actually
mostly consumers of communication if you
want to learn about communication
systems as sort of how they work that's
more the topic of six eight to nine
so for storage and computation a lot of
our goal is to be able to discover
abstractions where use of simplifying
the interface to these two storage and
computation distributed storage and
computation infrastructure so that it's
easy to build applications on top of it
and what that really means is that we
need to we'd like to be able to build
abstraction that hide the distributed
nature of these of these systems so the
dream which is rarely fully achieved but
the dream would be to be able to build
an interface that looks to an
application is if it's a non distributed
storage system just like a file system
or something that everybody already
knows how to program and has a pretty
simple model semantics we'd love to be
able to build interfaces that look and
act just like non distributed storage
and computation systems but are actually
you know vast extremely high performance
fault tolerant distributed systems
underneath so we both have abstractions
and you know as you'll see as a course
goes on we sort of you know only part of
the way there it's rare that you find an
abstraction for a distributed version of
storage or computation that has simple
behavior but he's just like the non just
non distributed version of storage that
everybody understands but people getting
better at this and we're gonna try to
study the ways and what people have
learned about building such abstractions
ok so what kind of what kind of topics
show up is we're considering these
abstractions the first one this first
topic general topic that we'll see a lot
a lot of the systems we looked at have
to do with implementation so for example
the kind of tools that you see a lot for
for ways people learn how to build these
systems are things like remote procedure
call
whose goal is to mask the fact that
we're communicating over an unreliable
Network another kind of implementation
topic that we'll see a lot is threads
which are a programming technique that
allows us to harness what allows us to
harness multi-core computers but maybe
more important for this class threads
are a way of structuring concurrent
operations in a way that's hopefully
simplifies the programmer view of those
concurrent operations and because we're
gonna use threads a lot it turns out
we're going to need to also you know
just as from an implementation level
spend a certain amount of time thinking
about concurrency control things like
locks and the main place that these
implementation ideas will come up in the
class they'll be touched on in many of
the papers but you're gonna come face
the face of all this in a big way in the
labs you need to build distributed you
know do the programming for distributed
system and these are like a lot of sort
of important tools you know beyond just
sort of ordinary programming these are
some of the critical tools that you'll
need to use to build distributed systems
another big topic that comes up in all
the papers we're going to talk about is
performance usually the high-level goal
of building a distributed system is to
get what people call scalable speed-up
so we're looking for scalability and
what I mean by scalability or scalable
speed-up is that if I have some problem
that I'm solving with one computer and I
buy a second computer to help me execute
my problem if I can now solve the
problem in half the time or maybe solve
twice as many problem instances you know
per minute on two computers as I had on
one then that's an example of
scalability so
sort of two times you know computers or
resources gets me you know two times
performance or throughput and this is a
huge hammer if you can build a system
that actually has this behavior Namie
that if you increase the number of
computers you throw at the problem by
some factor you get that factor more
throughput more performance out of the
system that's a huge win because you can
buy computers with just money right
whereas if in order to get the
alternative to this is that in order to
get more performance you have to pay
programmers to restructure your software
to get better performance to make it
more efficient or to apply some sort of
specialized techniques better algorithms
or something if you have to pay
programmers to fix your code to be
faster that's an expensive way to go
we'd love to be able just oh by thousand
computers instead of ten computers and
get a hundred times more throughput
that's fantastic and so this sort of
scalability idea is a huge idea in the
backs of people's heads when they're
like building things like big websites
that run on are you know building full
of computers if the building full of
computers is there to get a sort of
corresponding amount of performance but
you have to be careful about the design
in order to actually get that
performance so often the way this looks
when we're looking at diagrams or I'm
writing diagrams in this course is that
I'm not supposing we're building a
website ordinarily you might have a
website that you know has a HTTP server
let's say it has some types of users
many web browsers and they talk to a web
server running Python or PHP or whatever
sort of web server and the web server
talks to some kind of database
you know when you have one or two users
you can just have one computer running
both and maybe a computer for the web
server and a computer from the database
but maybe all of a sudden you get really
proper popular and you'll be up and
you've you know 100 million people sign
up your service ID how do you how do you
fix your c-certainly can it support
millions of people on a single computer
except by extremely careful
labor-intensive optimization but you
don't have time for so typically the way
you're going to speed things up the
first thing you do is buy more web
servers and just split the user so that
you know how few users or some fraction
the user go to a web server 1 and the
other half you send them to a web server
2 and because maybe you're building I
don't know what reddit or something
where all the users need to see the same
data ultimately you have all the web
servers talk to the backend and you can
keep on adding web servers for a long
time here and so this is a way of
getting parallel speed up on the web
server code you know if you're running
PHP or Python maybe it's not too
efficient as long as each individual web
server doesn't put too much load on the
database you can add a lot of web
servers before you run into problems but
this kind of scalability is rarely
infinite unfortunately certainly not
without serious thought and so what
tends to happen with these systems is
that at some point after you have 10 or
20 or 100 web servers all talking to the
same database now all of a sudden the
database starts to be a bottleneck and
adding more web servers no longer helps
so it's rare that you get full scale
ability to sort of infinite numbers of
adding infinite numbers of computers
some point you run out of gas because
the place at which you are adding more
computers is no longer the bottleneck by
having lots and lots of web servers we
basically moved the bottleneck
I think it's limiting performance from
the web servers to the database and at
this point actually you almost certainly
have to do a bit of design work because
it's rare that you can
there's any straightforward way to take
a single database and sort of refactor
things with it or you can take data
sorta in a single database and refactor
it so it's split over multiple databases
but it's often a fair amount of work and
because it's awkward but people many
people actually need to do this we're
gonna see a lot of examples in this
course in which the distributed system
people are talking about is a storage
system because the authors were running
you know something like a big website
that ran out of gas on a single database
or storage servers anyway so the
scalability story is we love to build
systems that scale this way but you know
it's hard to make it or takes work off
and design work to push this idea
infinitely far ok so another big topic
that comes up a lot is fault tolerance
if you're building a system with a
single computer in it well a single
computer often can stay up for years
like I have servers in my office that
have been up for years without crashing
you know the computer is pretty reliable
the operating systems reliable
apparently the power in my building is
pretty reliable so it's not uncommon to
have single computers it's just a for
amazing amount of time however if you're
building systems out of thousands of
computers then even if each computer can
be expected to stay up for a year with a
thousand computers that means you're
going to have like about three computer
failures per day in your set of a
thousand computers so solving big
problems with big distributed systems
turns sort of very rare fault tolerance
very real failure very rare failure
problems into failure problems that
happen just all the time in a system
with a thousand computers there's almost
certainly always something broken it's
always some computer that's either
crashed or mysteriously you know running
incorrectly or slowly or doing the wrong
thing or maybe there's some piece of the
network with a thousand computers we got
a lot of network cables and a lot of
network switches and so you know there's
always some network cable that somebody
stepped on and is unreliability or
network cable that fell out or some
networks which whose fan is broken and
the switch overheated and failed there's
always some little problem somewhere in
your building sized distributed system
so big scale turns problems from very
rare events you really don't have to
worry about that much into just constant
problems that means the failure has to
be really or the response the masking of
failures the ability to proceed without
failures just has to be built into the
design because there's always failures
and you know it's part of building you
know convenient abstractions for
application programmers we really need
that but to be able to build
infrastructure that as much as possible
hides the failures from application
programmers or masks them or something
so that every application programmer
doesn't have to have a complete
complicated story for all the different
kinds of failures that can occur there's
a bunch of different notions that you
can have about what it means to be fault
tolerant about a little more but you
know exactly what we mean by that we'll
see a lot of a lot of different flavors
but among the more common ideas you see
one is availability so you know some
systems are designed so that under some
kind certain kinds of failures not all
failures but certain kinds of failures
the system will keep operating despite
the failure while providing you know
undamaged service the same kind of
service it would have provided even if
there had been no failure so some
systems are available in that sense that
up and up you know so if you build a
replicated service that maybe has two
copies you know one of the replicas
replica servers fail fails maybe the
other server can continue operating
they both fail of course you can't you
know you can't promise availability in
that case so available systems usually
say well under certain set of failures
we're going to continue providing
service we're going to be available more
failures than that occur it won't be
available anymore
another kind of fault tolerance you
might you might have or in addition to
availability or by itself as
recoverability and what this means is
that if something goes wrong maybe the
service will stop working that it is
it'll simply stop responding to requests
and it will wait for someone to come
along and repair or whatever went wrong
but after the repair occurs the system
will be able to continue as if nothing
bad had gone wrong right so this is sort
of a weaker requirement than
availability because here we're not
going to do anything while while the
failed come until the failed component
has been repaired but the fact that we
can get up get going again without you
know but without any loss of correctness
is still a significant requirement it
means you know recoverable systems
typically need to do things like save
their latest date on disk or something
where they can get it back
you know after the power comes back up
and even among available systems in
order for a system to be useful in real
life usually what the way available
systems are SPECT is that they're
available until some number of failures
have happened if too many failures have
happened an available system will stop
working or you know will stop responding
at all but when enough things have been
repaired it'll continue operating so a
good available system will sort of be
recoverable as well in a sensitive to
many failures occur
it'll stop answering but then will
continue correctly after that so this is
what we love - this is what we'd love to
obtain the biggest hammer what we'll see
a number of approaches to solving these
problems there's really sort of
things that are the most important tools
we have in this department one is
non-volatile storage so that you know
something crash power fails or whatever
there's a building wide power failure we
can use non-volatile store it's like
hard drives or flash or solid-state
drives or something to sort of store a
check point or a log of the state of a
system and then when the power comes
back up or somebody repairs our power
suppliers notice what we'll be able to
read our latest state off the hard drive
and continue from there so so one tool
is sort of non-volatile storage and the
management of non-volatile storage just
Ning comes up a lot because non-volatile
storage tends to be expensive to update
and so a huge amount of the sort of
nitty-gritty of building sort of
high-performance fault-tolerant systems
is in you know clever ways to avoid
having to write the non-volatile storage
too much in the old days and even today
you know what writing non-volatile
storage meant was moving a disk arm and
waiting for a disk platter to rotate
both of which are agonizingly slow on
the scale of you know three gigahertz
microprocessors good things like flash
life is quite a bit better but still
requires a lot of thought to get good
performance out of and the other big
tool we have for fault tolerance is
replication and the management of
replicated copies is sort of tricky you
know that sort of he problem lurking in
any replicated system where we have two
servers each with a supposedly identical
copy of the system state the key problem
that comes up is always that the two
replicas will accidentally drift out of
sync and will stop being replicas right
and this is just you know with the back
of the every design that we're gonna see
for using replication to get fault
tolerance and lab - a lot - you're all
about management management of
replicated copies for fault tolerance
as you'll see it's pretty complex a
final topic final cross-cutting topic is
consistency so it's an example of what I
mean by consistency supposing we're
building a distributed storage system
and it's a key/value service so it just
supports two operations maybe there's a
put operation and you give it a key and
a value and that the storage system sort
of stashes away the value under as the
value for this key maintains it's just a
big table of keys and values and then
there's a good operation you the client
sends it a key and the storage service
is supposed to you know respond with the
value of the value it has stored for
that key right and this is kind of good
when I can't think of anything else as
an example of a distributed system all
Oh without key value services and
they're very useful right they're just
sort of a kind of fundamental simple
version of a storage system so of course
if you're an application programmer it's
helpful if these two operations kind of
have meanings attached to them that you
can go look in the manual and the manual
says you know what it what it means what
you'll get back if you call get right
and sort of what it means for you to
call put all right so it's immediate so
some sort of spec for what they meant
otherwise like who knows how can you
possibly write an application without a
description of what putting get are
supposed to do and this is the topic of
consistency and the reason why it's
interesting in distributed systems is
that both for performance and for fault
tolerant reasons fault tolerance reason
we often have more than one copy of the
data floating around so you know in a
non distributed system where you just
have a single server with a single table
there's often although not always but
there's often like relatively no
ambiguity about what pudding get could
possibly mean right in
to ative Lee you know what put means is
update the table and what get means is
just get me the version that's stored in
the table which but in a distributed
system where there's more than one copy
in the data due to replication or
caching or who knows what there may be
lots of different versions of this key
value pair floating around like if one
of the replicas you know if supposing
some client issues a put and you know
there's two copies of the the server so
they both have a key value table right
and maybe key one has value twenty on
both of them and then some client issues
a put nice we have client over here and
it's gonna send a put it wants to update
the value of one to be twenty-one all
right maybe it's counting stuff in this
key value server so sends a put with key
one and value twenty one it sends it to
the first server and it's about to send
the same put you know wants to update
both copies right it keeps them in sync
it's about to send this put but just
before it sends to put to the second
server crashes I power failure or bug an
operating system or something so now the
state were left in sadly is that we sent
this put and so we've updated one of the
two replicas didn't have value twenty
one but the other ones still with twenty
now somebody comes along and reads with
a get and they might get they want to
read the value associated with key one
they might get twenty one or they might
get twenty depending on who they talk to
and even if the rule is you always talk
to the top server first if you're
building a fault-tolerant system the
actual rule has to be oh you talk to the
top server first unless it's failed in
which case you talk to the bottom server
so either way someday you risk exposing
this stale copy of the data to some
future again it could be that many gets
get the updated twenty one and then like
next week all of a sudden some get
yields you know a week old copy of the
data so that's not very consistent
right so in order but you know it's the
kind of thing that could happen right
we're not careful so you know we need to
have we need to actually write down what
the rules are going to be about puts and
gets given this danger of due to
replication and it turns out there's
many different definitions you can have
of consistency you know many of them are
relatively straightforward many of them
sound like well I get yields the you
know value put by the most recently
completed put all right so that's
usually called strong consistency it
turns out also it's very useful to build
systems that have much weaker
consistency there for example do not
guarantee anything like a get sees the
value written by the most recent put and
the reason so there's there strongly
consistent systems they usually have
some version that gets seen most recent
puts although you have to there's a lot
of details to work out there's also
weekly consistent many sort of flavors
of weekly consistent systems that do not
make any such guarantee that you know
may guarantee well you're you know if
someone does a put then you may not see
the put you may see old values that
weren't updated by the put for an
unbounded amount of time maybe and the
reason for people being very interested
in wheat consistency schemes is that
strong consistency that is having Rezac
Chua lessee be guaranteed to see the
most recent right that's a very
expensive spec to implement because what
it means is almost certainly that you
have to somebody has to do a lot of
communication in order to actually
implement some notion of strong
consistency if you have multiple copies
it means that either the writer or the
reader or maybe both has to consult
every copy like in this case where you
know maybe a client crash left one
updated but not the other if we wanted
to implement strong
Sisseton see in them maybe a simple way
in this system we'd have readers read
both of the copies or if there's more
than one copy all the copies and use the
most recently written value that they
find but that's expensive that's a lot
of chitchat to read one value so in
order to avoid communication as much as
possible particularly if replicas are
far away people build weak systems that
might actually allow the stale read of
an old value in this case although
there's often more semantics attached to
that to try to make these weak schemes
more useful and we're this communication
problem you know strong consistency
requiring expensive communication where
this really runs you into trouble is
that if we're using replication for
fault tolerance then we really want the
replicas to have independent failure
probability to have uncorrelated failure
so for example putting both of the
replicas of our data in the same iraq in
the same machine room it's probably a
really bad idea
because if someone trips over the power
cable to that rack both of our copies of
our data are going to die because
they're both attached to the same power
cable in the same rack so in the search
for making replicas as independent and
failure as possible in order to get
decent fault tolerance people would love
to put different replicas as far apart
as possible like in different cities or
maybe on opposite sides of the continent
so an earthquake that destroys one data
center will be extremely unlikely to
also destroy the other data center that
as the other copy you know so we'd love
to be able to do that if you do that
then the other copy is thousands of
miles away and the rate at which light
travels means that it may take on the
order of milliseconds or tens of
milliseconds to communicate to a data
center across the continent in order to
update the other copy of the data and so
that makes this the communication
required for strong consistency for good
consistency potentially extremely
expensive like every time you want to do
one of these put opera
or maybe again depending on how you
implement it you might have to sit there
waiting for like 10 or 20 or 30
milliseconds in order to talk to both
copies of the data to ensure that
they're both updated or or both checked
to find the latest copy and that
tremendous expense right this is 10 or
20 or 30 milliseconds on machines that
after all I'll execute like a billion
instructions per second so we're wasting
a lot of potential instructions while we
wait people often go much weaker systems
you're allowed to only update the
nearest copy you're only consulted
nearest copy I mean there's a huge sort
of amount of academic and real-world
research on how to structure weak
consistency guarantees so they're
actually useful to applications and how
to take advantage of them in order to
actually get high performance alright so
that's a lightning preview of the
technical ideas in the course any
questions about this before I start
talking about MapReduce all right I want
to switch to Map Reduce that's a sort of
detailed case study that's actually
going to illustrate most of the ideas
that we've been talking about here now
produces a system that was originally
designed and built and used by Google I
think the paper dates back to 2004 the
problem they were faced with was that
they were running huge computations on
terabytes and terabytes of data like
creating an index of all of the content
of the web or analyzing the link
structure of the entire web in order to
identify the most important pages or the
most authoritative pages as you know the
whole web is what's even in those days
tens of terabytes of data building index
of the web is basically equivalent to a
sort running sort of the entire data
sort you know ones like reasonably
expensive and to run a sort on the
entire content to the way I've been a
single computer
how long would have taken but you know
it's weeks or months or years or
something so Google the time was
desperate to be able to run giant
computations on giant data on thousands
of computers in order that the
computations could finish rapidly it's
worth it to them to buy lots of
computers so that their engineers
wouldn't have to spend a lot of time
reading the newspaper or something
waiting for their big compute jobs to
finish and so for a while they had their
clever engineer or sort of handwrite you
know if you needed to write a web
indexer or some sort of Lincoln outlay a
blink analysis tool you know Google
bought the computers and they say here
engineers you know do write but never
whatever software you like on these
computers and you know they would
laborious ly write the sort of one-off
manually bitten software to take
whatever problem they were working on
and so to somehow farm it out to a lot
of computers and organize that
computation and get the data back if you
only hire engineers who are skilled
distributed systems experts maybe that's
ok although even then it's probably very
wasteful of engineering effort but they
wanted to hire people who were skilled
at something else and not necessarily
engineers who wanted to spend all their
time writing distributed system software
so they really needed some kind of
framework that would make it easy to
just have their engineers write the kind
of guts of whatever analysis they wanted
to do like the sort algorithm or a web
index or link analyzer or whatever just
write the guts of that application and
not be able to run it on a thousands of
computers without worrying about the
details of how to spread the work over
the thousands of computers how to
organize whatever data movement was
required how to cope with the inevitable
failures so they were looking for a
framework that would make it easy for
non specialists to be able to write and
run giant distributed computations and
so that's what MapReduce is all about
and the idea is that the programmer just
write the application designer
consumer of this distributed computation
I'm just be able to write a simple map
function and a simple reduce function
that don't know anything about
distribution and the MapReduce framework
would take care of everything else so an
abstract view of how what MapReduce is
up to is it starts by assuming that
there's some input and the input is
split up into some a whole bunch of
different files or chunks in some way so
we're imagining that no yeah you know
input file one and put file two etc you
know these inputs are maybe you know web
pages crawled from the web or more
likely sort of big files that contain
many web each of which contains many web
files crawl from the web all right and
the way Map Reduce
starts is that you're to find a map
function and the MapReduce framework is
gonna run your map function on each of
the input files and of course you can
see here there's some obvious
parallelism available can run the maps
in parallel so the each of these map
functions only looks as this input and
produces output the output that a map
function is required to produce is a
list you know it takes a file as input
and the file is some fraction of the
input data and it produces a list of key
value pairs as output the map function
and so for example let's suppose we're
writing the simplest possible MapReduce
example a word count MapReduce job goal
is to count the number of occurrences of
each word so your map function might
emit key value pairs where the key is
the word and the value is just one so
for every word at C so then this map
function will split the input up into
words or everywhere ditzies
it emits that word as the key and 1 as
the value and then later on will count
up all those ones in order to get the
final output so you know maybe input 1
has the word
a in it and the word B in it and so the
output the map is going to produce is
key a value one key B value one maybe
the second not communication sees a file
that has a B in it and nothing else so
it's going to implement output b1 maybe
this third input has an A in it and a C
in it alright so we run all these maps
on all the input files and we get this
intermediate with the paper calls
intermediate output which is for every
map a set of key value pairs as output
then the second stage of the computation
is to run the reduces and the idea is
that the MapReduce framework collects
together all instances from all maps of
each key word so the MapReduce framework
is going to collect together all of the
A's you know from every map every key
value pair whose key was a it's gonna
take collect them all and hand them to
one call of the programmer to find
reduce function and then it's gonna take
all the B's and collect them together of
course you know requires a real
collection because they were different
instances of key B were produced by
different indications of map on
different computers so we're not talking
about data movement I'm so we're gonna
collect all the B keys and hand them to
a different call to reduce that has all
of the B keys as its arguments and same
as C so there's going to be the
MapReduce framework will arrange for one
call to reduce for every key that
occurred in any of the math output and
you know for our sort of silly word
count example all these reduces have to
do or any one of them has to do is just
count the number of items passed to it
doesn't even have to look at the items
because it knows that each of them is
the word is responsible for plus one is
the value you don't have to look at
those ones we've just count
so this reduce is going to produce a and
then the count of its inputs this reduce
it's going to produce the key associated
with it and then count of its values
which is also two so this is what a
typical MapReduce job looks like the
high level just for completeness the
well some a little bit of terminology
the whole computation is called the job
anyone invocation of MapReduce is called
a task so we have the entire job and
it's made up of a bunch of math tasks
and then a bunch of produced tasks so
it's an example for this word count you
know the what the map and reduce
functions would look like the map
function takes a key in the value as
arguments and now we're talking about
functions like written in an ordinary
programming language like C++ or Java or
who knows what so this is just code
people ordinary people can write what a
map function for word count would do is
split the the key is the file name which
typically is ignored we really care what
the file name was and the V is the
content of this maps input file so V is
you know just contains all this text
we're gonna split V into words and then
for each word
we're just gonna emit and emit takes two
arguments mitts you know calmly map can
make emit is provided by the MapReduce
framework we get to produce we hand emit
a key which is the word and a value
which is the string one so that's it for
the map function and a word count map
function and MapReduce literally it
could be this simple
so there's sort of promise to make the
and you know this map function doesn't
know anything about distribution or
multiple computers or the fact we need
we need to move data across the network
or who knows what
this is extremely straightforward and
the reduce function for a word count the
reduce is called with you know remember
each reduce is called with sort of all
the instances of a given key on the
MapReduce framework calls reduce with
the key that it's responsible for and a
vector of all the values that the maps
produced associated with that key the
key is the word the values are all ones
we don't like here about them we only
care about how many they were and so
reduce has its own omit function that
just takes a value to be emitted as the
final output as the value for the this
key so we're gonna admit a length of
this array so this is also about as
simplest reduce functions have are and
in Map Reduce namely extremely simple
and requiring no knowledge about fault
tolerance or anything else alright any
questions about the basic framework yes
[Music]
you mean can you feed the output of the
reducers sort of oh yes oh yes in in in
in real life all right
in real life it is routine among
MapReduce users to you know define a
MapReduce job that took some inputs and
produce some outputs and then have a
second MapReduce job you know you're
doing some very complicated multistage
analysis or iterative algorithm like
PageRank for example which is the
algorithm Google uses to sort of
estimate how important or influential
different webpages are that's an
iterative algorithm is sort of gradually
converges on an answer and if you
implement in MapReduce which I think
they originally did you have to run the
MapReduce job multiple times and the
output of each one is sort of you know
list of webpages with an updated sort of
value or weight or importance for each
webpage so it was routine to take this
output and then use it as the input to
another MapReduce job oh yeah well yeah
you need to sort of set things up the
output you need to rate the reduced
function sort of in the knowledge that
oh I need to produce data that's in the
format or as the information required
for the next MapReduce job I mean this
actually brings up a little bit of a
shortcoming in the MapReduce framework
which is it's great if you are if the
algorithm you need to run is easily
expressible as a math followed by this
sort of shuffling of the data by key
followed by a reduce and that's it
my MapReduce is fantastic for algorithms
that can be cast in that form and we're
furthermore each of the maps has to be
completely independent and
are required to be functional pure
functional functions that just look at
their arguments and nothing else
you know that's like it's a restriction
and it turns out that many people want
to run much longer pipelines that
involve lots and lots of different kinds
of processing and with MapReduce you
have to sort of cobble that together
from multiple MapReduce distinct
MapReduce jobs and more advanced systems
which we will talk about later in the
course are much better at allowing you
to specify the complete pipeline of
computations and they'll do optimization
you know the framework realizes all the
stuff you have to do and organize much
more complicated efficiently optimize
much more complicated computations
from the programmers point of view it's
just about map and reduce from our point
of view it's going to be about the
worker processes and the worker servers
that that are they're part of MapReduce
framework that among many other things
call the map and reduce functions so
yeah from our point of view we care a
lot about how this is organized by the
surrounding framework this is sort of
the programmers view with all the
distributive stuff stripped out yes
sorry I gotta say it again oh you mean
where does the immediate data go okay so
there's two questions one is when you
call a MIT what happens to the data and
the other is where the functions run so
the actual answer is that first where
the stuff rotten there's a number of say
a thousand servers um actually the right
thing to look at here is figure one in
the paper sitting underneath this in the
real world there's some big collection
of servers and we'll call them maybe
worker servers or workers and there's
also a single master server that's
organizing the whole computation and
what's going on here is the master
server for know knows that there's some
number of input files you know five
thousand input files and it farms out in
vacations of map to the different
workers so it'll send a message to
worker seven saying please run you know
this map function on such-and-such an
input file and then the worker function
which is you know part of MapReduce and
knows all about Map Reduce well then
read the file read the input whatever
whichever input file and call this map
function with the file name value as its
arguments then that worker process will
employees what implements in it and
every time the map calls emit the worker
process will write this data to files on
the local disk so what happens to map
emits and is they produce files on the
map workers local discs that are
accumulating all the keys and values
produced by the maps run on that worker
so at the end of the math phase what
we're left with is all those worker
machines each of which has the output of
some of whatever maps were run on that
worker machine then the MapReduce
workers arrange to move the data to
where it's going to be needed for the
reduces so and since and a you know in a
typical big computation you know this
this reduce indication is going to need
all map output that
mentioned the key a but it's gonna turn
out you know this is a simple example
but probably in general every single map
indication will have produce lots of
keys including some instances of key a
so typically in order before we can even
run this reduce function the MapReduce
framework that is the MapReduce worker
running on one of our thousand servers
is going to have to go talk to every
single other of the thousand servers and
say look you know I'm gonna run the
reduce for key a please look at the
intermediate map output stored in your
disk and fish out all of the instances
of key a and send them over the network
to me so the reduce worker is going to
do that it's going to fetch from every
worker all of the instances of the key
that it's responsible for that the
master has told it to be responsible for
and once it's collected all of that data
then it can call reduce and the reduce
function itself calls reduce omit which
is different from the map in it and what
reduces emit does is writes the output
to a file in a cluster file service that
Google uses so here's something I
haven't mentioned I haven't mentioned
where the input lives and where the
output lives they're both files because
any piece of input we want the
flexibility to be able to read any piece
of input on any worker server that means
we need some kind of network file system
to store the input data and so indeed
the paper talks about this thing called
GFS or Google file system and GFS is a
cluster file system and BFS actually
runs on exactly the same set of workers
that work our servers that run MapReduce
and the input GFS just automatically
when you you know it's a file system you
can read in my files it just
automatically splits up any big file you
store on it across lots of servers and
64 megabyte chunks so if you write
if you view of ten terabytes of crawled
web page contents and you just write
them to GFS even as a single big file
GFS will automatically split that vast
amount of data up into 64 kilobyte
chunks distributed evenly over all of
the GFS servers which is to say all the
servers that Google has available and
that's fantastic that's just what we
need if we then want to run a MapReduce
job that takes the entire crawled web as
input the data is already stored in a
way that split up evenly across all the
servers and so that means that the map
workers you know we're gonna launch you
know if we have a thousand servers we're
gonna launch a thousand map workers each
reading one 1000s at the input data and
they're going to be able to read the
data in parallel from a thousand GFS
file servers thus getting now tremendous
total read throughput you know the read
through put up a thousand servers
so so are you thinking maybe that Google
has one set of physical machines among
GFS and a separate set of physical
machines that run MapReduce jobs okay
right so the question is what does this
arrow here actually involve and the
answer that actually it sort of changed
over the years as Google's
involve this system but you know what
this in those general case if we have
big files stored in some big Network
file system like you know it's like GFS
is a bit like AFS you might have used on
Athena where you go talk to some
collection and your data split over big
collection o servers you have to go talk
to those servers over the network to
retrieve your data in that case what
this arrow might represent is the meta
MapReduce worker process has to go off
and talk across the network to the
correct GFS server or maybe servers that
store it's part of the input and fetch
it over the network to the MapReduce
worker machine in order to pass the map
and that's certainly the most general
case and that was eventually how
MapReduce actually worked in the world
of this paper though and and if you did
that that's a lot of network
communication are you talking about ten
terabytes of data and we have moved 10
terabytes across their data center
network which you know data center
networks wanting gigabits per second but
it's still a lot of time to move tens of
terabytes of data in order to try to and
indeed in the world of this paper in
2004 the most constraining bottleneck in
their MapReduce system was Network
throughput because they were running on
a network if you sort of read as far as
the evaluation section their network
their network as was they had thousands
of machines
whatever and they would collect machines
they would plug machines and you know
each rack of machines and you know an
Ethernet switch for that rack or
something but then you know they all
need to talk to each other but there was
a route Ethernet switch that all of the
Rockies are net switches talked to and
this one and you know so if you just
pick some Map Reduce worker and some GFS
server you know chances are at least
half the time the communication between
them has to pass through this one
wouldn't switch their routes which had
only some amount of total throughput
which I forget you know some number of
gigabits per second and I forget the
number well but when I did the division
that is divided up to the total
throughput available in the routes which
by the roughly 2000 servers that they
used in the papers experiments what I
got was that each machine share of the
route switch or of the total network
capacity was only 50 megabits per second
per second in their setup 50 megabits
per second per machine and then might
seem like a lot 50 megabits gosh
millions and millions but it's actually
quite small compared to how fast a disks
Ron or CPUs run and so this with their
network this 50 megabits per second was
like a tremendous limit and so they
really stood on their heads in the
design described in the paper to avoid
using the network and they played a
bunch of tricks to avoid sending stuff
over the network when they possibly
could avoid it one of them was they
would they ran the gfs servers and the
MapReduce workers on the same set of
machines so they have a thousand
machines they'd run GFS they implement
their GFS service on that thousand
machines and run MapReduce on the same
thousand machines and then when the
master was splitting up the map work and
sort of farming it out to different
workers it would cleverly when it was
about to run the map that was going to
read from input file one it would figure
out from GFS which server actually holds
input file one on its local disk and it
would send the map for that input file
to the MapReduce software on the same
machine so that by default this arrow
was actually local local read from the
local disk and did not involve the
network and you know depending on
failures or load or whatever that
couldn't always do that but almost all
the maps would be run on the very same
machine and stored the data thus saving
them vast amount of time that they would
otherwise had to wait to move the input
data across the network the next trick
they played is that map as I mentioned
before stores this output on the local
disk of the machine that you run the map
on so again storing the output of the
map does not require network
communication he's not immediately
because the output stored in the disk
however we know for sure that one way or
another in order to group together all
of you know by the way the MapReduce is
defined in order to group together all
of the values associated with the given
key and pass them to a single invocation
to produce on some machine this is going
to require network communication we're
gonna you know we want to need to fetch
all bays and give them a single
machine that have to be moved across the
network and so this shuffle this
movement of the keys from is kind of
originally stored by row and on the same
machine that ran the map we need them
essentially to be stored on by column on
the machine that's going to be
responsible for reduce this
transformation of row storage
essentially column storage is called the
paper calls a shuffle and it really that
required moving every piece of data
across the network from the map that
produced it to the reduce that would
need it and now it's like the expensive
part of the MapReduce yeah
you're right you can imagine a different
definition in which you have a more kind
of streaming reduce I don't know I
haven't thought this through I don't
know why whether that would be feasible
or not certainly as far as programmer
interface like if the goal their
number-one goal really was to be able to
make it easy to program by people who
just had no idea of what was going on in
the system so it may be that you know
this speck this is really the way reduce
functions look and you know in C++ or
something like a streaming version of
this is now starting to look I don't
know how it look probably not this
symbol but you know maybe it could be
done that way and indeed many modern
systems people got a lot more
sophisticated with modern things that
are the successors the MapReduce and
they do indeed involve processing
streams of data often rather than this
very batch approach there is a batch
approach in the sense that we wait until
we get all the data and then we process
it so first of all that you then have to
have a notion of finite inputs right
modern systems often do indeed you
streams and and are able to take
advantage of some efficiencies do that
MapReduce okay so this is the point at
which this shuffle is where all the
network traffic happens this can
actually be a vast amount of data so if
you think about sort if you're sorting
the the output of the sort has the same
size as the input to the sort so that
means that if you're you know if your
input is 10 terabytes of data and you're
running a sort you're moving 10
terabytes of data across a network at
this point and your output will also be
10 terabytes and so this is quite a lot
of data and then indeed it is from any
MapReduce jobs although not all there's
some that significantly reduce the
amount of data at these stages somebody
mentioned Oh what if you want to feed
the output of reduce into another
MapReduce job and indeed that was often
what people wanted to do and
in case the output of the reduce might
be enormous like four sort or web and
mixing the output of the produces on ten
terabytes of input the output of the
reduces again gonna be ten terabytes so
the output of the reduce is also stored
on GFS and the system would you know
reduce would just produce these key
value pairs but the MapReduce framework
would gather them up and write them into
giant files on GFS and so there was
another round of network communication
required to get the output of each
reduce to the GFS server that needed to
store that reduce and because you might
think that they could have played the
same trick with the output of storing
the output on the GFS server that
happened to run the MapReduce worker
that ran the reduce and maybe they did
do that but because GFS as well as
splitting data for performance also
keeps two or three copies for fault
tolerance that means no matter what you
need to write one copy of the data
across a network to a different server
so there's a lot of network
communication here and a bunch here also
and I was this network communication
that really limited the throughput in
MapReduce
in 2004 in 2020 because this network
arrangement was such a limiting factor
for so many things people wanted to do
in datacenters modern data center
networks are a lot faster at the root
than this was and so you know one
typical data center network you might
see today actually has many root instead
of a single root switch that everything
has to go through you might have you
know many root switches and each rack
switch has a connection to each of these
sort of replicated root switches and the
traffic is split up among the root
switches so modern data center networks
have far more network throughput and
because of that actually modern I think
Google sort of stopped using MapReduce a
few years ago but before they stopped
using it the modern MapReduce actually
no longer tried to run the maps on the
same machine as the data stored on they
were happy to vote the data from
anywhere because they just assumed that
was extremely fast okay we're out of
time for MapReduce
we have a lab due at the end of next
week
in which you'll write your own somewhat
simplified MapReduce so have fun with
that
and see you on Thursday